und alex nicht um den streak rat gewählt
[Musik]
alles scheint es war ein video ist voll
tief habe ich das gefühl aber ist nicht
auf einzelne gut herzlich willkommen
ich habe mir für heute mal wieder was
ganz spektakuläres 1 verlassen ich
wollte dich wieder eine schon längst
gemacht haben kam aber irgendwie ich
dazu mal vorweg um ganz ehrlich zu sein
was ist bitte sowas ist dass das ist
doch längst wieder auto da sind die
beide kaputt der kaputt und der ist hier
kaputt
ich kenne mich hat jemand den glauben
gegeben und die leute spaß bereite aber
ich habe mir irgendwie vor einer woche
gedacht er ist ganz ehrlich leute in
vitte nach können nicht das einzige sein
was du trainierst ich meine es cool ich
jetzt tue ich das werde auf den zug mit
diesen dingen weil ich halt wirklich
nichts zu tun hatte außer so zu machen
ich hab ein bisschen google nach
alternativen zu fit bin und hab mir auch
ein paar sachen bestellt wir haben hier
nämlich zum einen die schnellste sein
ich habe keine angst damit anfangen dann
habe ich mir einen ultimativen youtube
ist es denn nicht zum ersten mal
ausgepackt ist das schöne scheiße und
alles was auch immer also wir haben ein
viertel stick einfindet und ganz viele
verschiedene für die spielzeuge
um ehrlich zu sein ich bin darüber klagt
was die funktion dieser teile angeht ich
weiß das ist ja ganz offensichtlich das
kann sich drehen
was könnt ihr hier jetzt hat die
irgendeine funktion jetzt eine murmel
drin ich weiß man dass die oder was auch
immer das ist auch obst als er
übertreibt mit vielleicht muss man als
emmi kaputtmachen alter ich habe leute
guckt euch das woran also ob mir das
glaubt oder nicht ich habe diese teile
bestellt weil ich halt alternativen zu
finden wenn ein gebuchter oder sie sind
einfach viertels spiels steht auch hier
drauf und lesen kann weiß was für eine
scheiße wenn ihr diese dinge erkennt und
den winter hinter dann lasse ich das
besser auf jeden fall in den kommentaren
wissen ich habe keine ahnung das ist ein
blödes plastikding mit ambo drin
als nächstes kommt es zum vize zu von
dem hier erwarte ich jetzt ein bisschen
haben wir einen schalter
wir haben hier so ein training noch ein
drehten dann einmal so füllt teile die
bei einem würfel und das kann man auch
drehen und was kann ich meine bestellung
weil ich fange ich an zu weinen ich
dachte ich hab jetzt folge einen neuen
fan die sachen gefunden
ich kann ja einfach gar nicht ohne spaß
an die vielen diese scheiße hier
produzieren denke damit können wir
sofort vom markt drängen passiert würde
ich mal sagen eine acht von zehn
und dass sie jetzt höchstens nein das
ist einfach scheiße der sind davon ist
im unterricht irgendwie oder keine
ahnung wo auch immer ein bisschen was in
der hand zu haben befindet sich in der
hand zu haben aber ich finde wo es
erhält auch so einfach davon statistik
vor die selbstständig jetzt in dieses
ding von dem ich eigentlich am wenigsten
erwartungen hatte ist auch keine
beschreibung vor
[Musik]
analysten dass sie den krieg hat gewählt
ich muss erst mal kurz hinter der last
und auch das ding noch jemals zustande
kam
alter sie machen damit echt kraft in
sachen was kann ich noch gar alleine
stehen leute macht das auf keinen fall
ich glaube dass auf die autos werde auf
seinem acker
ich verstehe nicht warum nicht einfach
stehen bleibt also ich hab mich um
ernste sein wissen in die sting verliebt
man mag es kaum glauben aber es macht
echte menge spaß
naja wenn sich was davon ist es auf
jeden fall
die abstimmung findet bombastisches
diktator imad ich verlinke euch alle
produkte meinen der video beschreibung
werner becker traut euch auf jeden fall
anders drauf ich dass sie dadurch
gefallen hat auf jeden fall nach oben da
und wir sehen uns morgen wieder morgen
konnten richtig richtig harten video und
zwar habe ich ein neues baby produkt
ausprobieren
haut rein